- We did it, Reddit!
Nvidia was so embarrassed by the specs
of the RTX 4080 12 gig
that they unlaunched it
and now in its place
we've got the RTX 4070 TI.
It's the same GPU but
with a different name.
Oh.
But it got a $100 price drop,
which unfortunately isn't quite the W
that you might think it is.
While theoretically there
will be 4070 TIs for $700,
there are no first party
founder's edition cards,
meaning that that MSRP
is really just that,
a manufacturer's suggested retail price.
And later we're gonna get into
why no one really follows
Nvidia's suggestions anymore.
The card that we were sent
for review, for example,
is lightly overclocked
and costs 850 US dollars,
meaning that I kind of
have to evaluate this
as a 4080 12 gig with a name
change and a 5.5% discount.
This thing better be amazing.
Amazing like our sponsor!
- Ridge Wallet.
Ridge Wallet has redefined
the traditional wallet
with its compact frame
and RFID blocking plates.
Keep your wallet bulged down
and use our offer code Linus
to save 10% and get
free worldwide shipping.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Right outta the gate,
the 4070 TI is in trouble
with specs that I might
have imagined on a 4070
or even a 4060 Super that
puts its total bandwidth
somewhere in between the
RTX 3070 and 3070 TI.
So it's only chance is if it's other specs
can pick up the slack.
Fortunately on paper, the
4070 TI's core performance
should contribute to a sizable uplift.
It has 25% more CUDA
course than its predecessor
and they're clocked substantially higher.
That's a good sign even before
the architectural improvements
thanks to its Ada Lovelace cores.
This means improved ray
tracing and tensor cores
and shader execution reordering,
which optimizes the order of the data
sent to the ray-tracing cores.
Nvidia called this as big
an innovation for GPUs
as out of order execution was for CPUs,
though if our recent
poll is any indication,
most of you won't be making
use of it anytime soon.
Of course, how would you,
given the ongoing popularity
of the 10 series GPUs,
which are turning seven
years old this year.
Nvidia's marketing push for the 4070 TI
is that it makes for a great upgrade
from 10 and 20 series
GPUs, which okay, Nvidia,
let's play along with that for a moment.
Compared to the GTX 1080 and 1080 TI 4K,
we are looking at a
staggering two to three times
improvement in "Shadow of the Tomb Raider"
taking us from sub 60-FPSs
averages to over a hundred.
"Modern Warfare 2" is even more impressive
at up to four and a half
times the performance.
We're talking cinematic to
playable (snaps) just like that.
1440p does give our 10
series cards a better chance,
but we're still looking at two
to four times the performance
in both of these games,
making this truly an incredible upgrade
over the 10 series GPU.
No, no, no, no, this is stupid.
I don't need to spend $850 to
upgrade a seven year old card.
Ah, that's better.
To see how it really competes,
we tested the RTX 4070 TI,
not against what Nvidia wants,
but against a truly
intimidating stack of GPUs.
As an FYI, even though
our review was so recent,
we sanity checked our RX
7000 series GPU results
since driver updates have actually changed
their performance
characteristics since launch.
We've also revalidated any of
the numbers that we've reused
and we'll talk a bit more about our plans
for our GPU testing
methodology in a future video.
Even with the full lineup,
"Shadow of the Tomb Raider"
has the 4070 TI within
about 8% of the RTX 3090 TI,
which is a fairly impressive achievement
considering that it is
nominally a 70 series GPU.
What's more impressive though
is that it gets handily beat
by the RX 7900 XT.
Yes, yes, I'm aware that
that GPU costs $50 more,
but it's the beginning of a pattern
that repeats itself first in "F1 2022,"
where the 4070 TI gets stomped well beyond
what that price difference would suggest.
Starting the 4070 TI off
on pretty rocky ground.
"Hitman 3" continues this
floundering performance
with frame rates nearly
on par with the 3090 TI,
but well off of AMD and the RTX 4080
that it used to share a name with,
and it's really more of the same story
with "Red Dead Redemption 2,"
"Assassin's Creed: Valhalla,"
"Modern Warfare 2," and "Cyberpunk,"
though "Cyberpunk" is more of a beat down
thanks to that game's memory
hungry nature, we think.
Thankfully for Nvidia, "Forza Horizon 5"
gives the 4070 TI some breathing room
as it meets or beats the 7900 XT
and even beats the 3090 TI.
Though it's still a good
13% off of the real 4080.
It's a really good thing that
they changed that naming.
For 4K gaming then, the RTX 4070 TI
ends up firmly behind both
of AMD's Radeon 7000 series
and everything from Nvidia
from the 3090 TI and up,
which seems to suggest that
Nvidia basically looked at
3090 TI pricing on eBay and said,
"hmm, about like that sounds good."
Maybe things will look
a bit better at 1440p.
Eh?
And they kind of do.
Now that memory bandwidth
is less of an issue,
"Shadow of the Tomb
Raider" sees the 4070 TI
pull ahead of the 3090 TI
and close the gap on its bigger siblings.
Though it still falls behind
AMD, if only slightly.
"Hitman" sees the 4070
TI backsliding a little
in relation to the 7900
XT while maintaining
its performance improvement
over the 3090 TI,
but this doesn't carry
over into "Cyberpunk,"
"Modern Warfare 2," and
"Assassin's Creed: Valhalla,"
where we're looking at
pretty much the same relative
performance as our 4K tests.
"Forza," however, picks up spectacularly
with the 4070 TI sitting
firmly in third place,
contributing to a generally
rosier picture at 1440p overall.
With roughly equal
performance to a 3090 TI then
and a small enough gap from the 7900 XT,
it looks almost compelling in
this overpriced GPU hellscape.
And that's before we turn on ray tracing,
which works fine, right?
I mean, we knew it would be superior
to the 7,900 XT since that's a stronghold
for Nvidia at this point,
but what was surprising
is that it wasn't by
as much as we expected.
I was shocked to see the 7900
XTX actually outperform it
at 4K in everything except for "Cyberpunk"
where the ray tracing cores
seemed to be doing a better job
potentially thanks to SER.
At 1440p, things, again, get a bit better,
for the 4070 TI with only a mild loss
against the 7900 XTX in
"Shadow of the Tomb Raider"
and overall better performance
in the rest of the suite.
"Cyberpunk" hits AMD even harder here,
but that doesn't help the 4070
TI against its own brothers
who pull away significantly.
That weak memory bandwidth
seems to be really holding it back here.
Interestingly, when we turned on DLSS 3.0
to test if the 4070 TI's
diminished tensor core count
would prevent it from keeping up,
it did just fine in cyberpunk
with a similar performance uplift
to the 4080 and the 4090,
but then we did not see the
same thing in "F1 2022."
We tried a bunch of
different settings here
and nothing we did change
to the outcome at all.
We think this could be a driver issue
considering that "Cyberpunk"
of all games is fine.
So we've reached out to Nvidia about it
to see what they have to say.
If they respond in time for this video,
we'll have their response
on screen right now,
and I'll just use this
time to tell you all about
how delicious water tastes
from your LTTstore.com water bottle.
It's great.
In ray tracing then, the 4070 TI
is looking a lot like an RTX 3090 TI
when we look at the overall
picture and as expected,
ray tracing performance for the price
is superior to anything from Team Red.
Unfortunately for Nvidia,
the vast majority of our
viewers have never once enabled
ray tracing and under 15%
of you actively use it.
So at least for you guys, it
might not be the trump card
that they were hoping it would be.
What might be though is productivity,
because remember, as much as
we like to talk about games,
these GPUs for a lot of people,
end up used for work too.
Starting with Nvidia's current
ave in the whole, Blender.
The 4070 TI manages a
solid 43% improvement
over its predecessor, but
falls behind the RTX 3090 TI
and especially the RTX 4080,
with performance against the latter
being a mostly linear relationship
with the difference in
ray tracing core count.
Things pick up a little with Procyon,
with the video editing
suite giving the 4070 TI
very close performance
against the 3090 TI,
though still slightly behind
both Radeon 7,000 series cards.
Photo editing is interesting, however.
Most of the results are within
a couple of percentage
points, which seems to suggest
that any modern GPU will be sufficient,
but this doesn't tell the whole story.
As more machine learning
effects and filters
trickle into your workflow,
you can expect to see
these numbers change,
and it could be a pretty
solid advantage for Nvidia.
Da Vinci Resolve gives the
4070 TIs end bank encoders
a run for their money
with what looks to be
a memory bandwidth bottleneck,
slowing it down considerably
next to its bigger siblings.
It manages to be a little bit faster
than its bandwidth
difference would suggest,
but this unfortunately means
that out of our test suite
it only really beats the
RTX 3060 in export speed.
Topaz AI though is a better
story for the 4070 TI
where it's enhanced core architecture
makes shorter work of this GPGP workload
than even the RTX 3090 TI,
though AMD is the one who
ends up stealing the show here
with even the last gen 6900 XT
putting up comparable numbers.
The spec suites are another
strong suit for Nvidia
ever since the 20 series,
and the RTX 4070 TI trades
blows with the 3090 TI
in a lot of these tests,
which is a good thing.
Unfortunately though there
are cases like 3DS Max
and SolidWorks that give
the 4070 TI some trouble,
likely again, thanks to its
relative shortage of cores
and limited memory bandwidth.
However, energy and medical
end up being standout wins
for the 4070 TI and in all cases,
it's substantially
faster than the RTX 3080,
let alone the 3070 TI.
That ignores AMD, of course, though,
whose cards all spank it across the board
with the exception of 3DS Max.
Siemens NX as usual will be ignored
in our final performance tallies
since this version is old enough
to not have proper
support for Nvidia GPUs,
but we're putting the data in here
in case you're interested.
Finally, the 4070 TI
outperforms the RTX 3090 TI
in every part of SPECworkstation,
although as with Viewperf,
AMD maintains big wins
over all of Nvidia's cards
across most of the suite
with the exceptions of
media and entertainment
and GPU compute.
So much for that stronghold.
Overall performance looks like a 3090 TI,
but at a lower cost and
hopefully a lower power draw,
but it really does depend
on what you're doing.
If you're into 3D
rendering or GPU compute,
you're gonna get a lot
more bang out of a 4070 TI
than the 3090 TI, which could
make it an attractive option
for the price and
hopefully the power draw.
If you're into video editing however,
it's not a worthy upgrade
over even the 3070 TI
and you might want to consider
a 7,000 series Radeon instead
if you need a new GP today,
preferably one with hardware
AV encoding support.
So if we're looking at an RTX 3090
or a 3090 TI equivalent here,
surely at the 4070 TI should
be more energy efficient too.
Well, in MSI Kombustor,
it pulled the lowest
out of not only the 40 series family,
but also when compared to
AMD's price competitors,
hovering at around 280
watts most of the time
and never breaking past
its 285 watt rating.
When we switch to a more
real world test, "F1 22,"
the story stays pretty much the same,
this time with the card
hovering at around 275 watts.
That is well with in
spec even though our card
is a factory overclocked model.
It's worth noting by the way guys,
that in our Radiant RX
7,900 series review,
we made a mistake when we changed the way
that we collected our data
and we initially showed
total graphics power
and total board power in the same chart.
Those measurements are not comparable.
So this time we are strictly
using total board power
and in the future we're planning to use
external equipment for better accuracy
than board sensors or Nvidia's P-cap.
Stay tuned for that.
When we zoom in on our
power consumption results
for "Forza Horizon Five" at 1440p,
the power consumption
without a frame rate cap
is pretty much in line with the RTX 4080,
which actually is not a great thing
considering that it ran
about five to 10 FPSs slower.
However, when we cap the
frame rate to a hundred,
it actually lines up so perfectly,
I almost thought the graph
only had three lines.
AMD's cards by comparison ran about
30 to 50 watts higher most of the time.
That works out to about
17 watts per frame less
than the Radeon 7900 XT when it's uncapped
and a good 35 watts when capped.
Not a bad efficiency story,
and no high idle power consumption bugs
when connected to different monitors
like we saw with AMD's 7000 series.
Now thermals are gonna be
a difficult conversation,
since there isn't a like a reference
or a founder's edition of the RTX 4070 TI
with a standard cooler for us to test.
With that in mind then,
take these results with a grain of salt.
Starting with Kombustor.
It's not looking great
for our tough OC edition
of the 4070 TI, which quickly ramps up
past 80 degrees and holds
there throughout our run.
This is well above the RTX
4080 with its founders cooler
and more in line with the 4090.
"F1 22" pushes the 4070 TI even higher
relative to the 4090, sticking again
to around the 80 degree mark.
To be clear, this isn't
the end of the world,
as long as the core
clocks are high and stable
at these temperatures.
And high they probably will be.
I suspect that the only 4070 TIs
that you will find readily
available at launch
will be factory overclocked like ours,
which managed among the highest clocks
that we've ever seen on a GPU,
even though it can't maintain
full-boosting Kombustor
and has a little bit more
wobble than the RTX 4080.
It's worth saying again though
that your mileage will vary
depending on a given card's
cooling setup and B bios.
"F1 22" is a more realistic load
and sees that variation calm down a bit
with the 4070 TI with it regularly hitting
our factory overclocked cards
2.7 gigahertz boost clock.
But again, your mileage may vary
once the first summer heat wave strikes,
because as you guys saw,
we're flying pretty close
to the sun on our thermals,
and that's in a temperature
controlled room.
As the saying goes, there's no
such thing as a bad product,
only a bad price.
So it's time to talk about that.
Originally announced at $900,
as the RTX 4080 12 gig,
the current starting price,
now that it is the 4070 TI, is $800.
That's a hundred dollars less.
But not only is that $200 higher
than the RTX 3070 TI MSRP was at launch,
that price only barely puts
it in a competitive position
against the Radeon RX7900
XT in typical raster gaming,
and it's not even
guaranteed to net you 60 FPS
if you do turn on ray tracing,
making some flavor of DLS a necessity
unless you want dial back the settings.
On an $850 card, it's still
a lot for what, by its name,
should be a high mid-range GPU,
not a step-down enthusiast class one.
So how does Nvidia justify
its astronomical price tag
for a 70 series GPU
that as we said before,
really seems more like a 60 super?
To put it bluntly, they don't.
And as far as they're concerned,
they shouldn't have to.
I mean, you think they
renamed the RTX 4070 TI
out of the goodness of their hearts
and it was a big win?
No!
Up until literally just last week,
it was still up in the air whether Nvidia
would drop the price at all
compared to the announced $900 price
for the RTX 4080 12 gig.
It took their business
partners begging and pleading
with them to make that
happen, and that was in spite
of the reportedly atrocious
sales figures for the RTX 4080
and the Radeon 7900 XT's existence
at that very same price point.
It's good they yielded, but
they still have more work to do.
Nvidia reportedly offered
partners some compensation
for the work involved in the rebranding,
but at this point we
haven't heard confirmation
that they intend to do the
same for this new MSRP.
That means that if this chart
showing the meager scraps of margin
that Nvidia leads for its
partners is to be believed,
any MSRP cards that
you see are going to be
very limited in stock and
essentially just for show
so that media like us will be suckers
and talk about how this card is 799.
Board makers, like any other business,
are not gonna go go out
of their way to lose money
if Nvidia hasn't adjusted the pricing.
Asus's top end strict 4070 TI then
is just $150 less than a
4080 founder's edition,
making even that card
look good by comparison.
Reports from ASUS
suggest that the tough OC
will be the most plentiful skew,
but from conversations we've had
with Memory Express here in Canada,
that's actually been the opposite
for the rest of the 40 series lineup
where almost no tough cards exist.
So what it looks like is Nvidia
is pointing at the price saying,
"but it can't be expensive.
We set it at 799.
See?"
But the partners have absolutely no way
of achieving that in the real world.
I'm having a hard time
figuring out Nvidia's game here
to be honest with you.
The GPU market has reportedly
hit a 20 year sales low
thanks to a combination of high prices,
the mining crash, and extenuating
economic circumstances,
and yet Nvidia seems determined
to pour water on the fire
expecting a huge premium even on products
in the high slash mid-tier
of their product stack.
I mean, don't forget.
As much as we focus on desktop GPUs
and PC gaming on this channel,
the real competition for a card like this
could easily be an Xbox or a PlayStation 5
either of which would frankly be
a much more compelling
value to the average gamer.
And I feel like Nvidia, if
they don't turn things around,
is at risk of losing PC gaming customers
long term to the console side.
It's starting to almost look like
a Microsoftian good, bad, good cycle
that they've been on for
the last few years here.
10 series is great, 20
series was a wet fart,
30 series kickstarted a whole
new generation of PC gamers
in spite of the pandemic price hikes,
and as product development
cycles run for longer and longer
with each new generation,
the impact of this kind of
please people 50% of the time,
piss them off 50% of the time
starts to become more dramatic.
And Nvidia clearly hasn't
learned their lesson yet.
I mean, Apple and Tesla have proven
that people will still buy your product
even if you treat them badly,
but that only holds true
if you have the absolute
best products on the market.
It doesn't build loyalty.
So this strategy around the 4070 TI
and especially the 4080 clearly
isn't it for the long term.
It is time for Nvidia to focus
on squeezing out margins less
and delighting customers more.
Now, AMD is not innocent here to be clear.
While the RX 7900 series is
a better value than the 4080,
the 4070 TI is content to
price itself right in line
with its performance against the 7900 XT,
a card that also should probably be more
like $700 considering its
80 class performance level.
Nvidia enabled AMD then
to charge more themselves
through their own astronomical pricing,
and AMD is in turn enabling
Nvidia to normalize those prices
by providing a comparably fair price
on this step down product,
which Nvidia can then compete with
as they both run down the stack.
As long as this continues
and as long as Nvidia
keeps trying to kill Moore's law
on the collective consciousness,
things are never going to change.
Nowhere is this attitude more apparent
than Nvidia's positioning
for the RTX 4070 TI,
not as competition for AMD or even against
a 30 series card, but as an upgrade
from 20 series and 10 series GPUs.
And I mean, yes, it is an upgrade,
but it would also be an upgrade
over a toaster or a literal potato,
especially if that potato
is seven years old.
I mean, even an ARC
GPU would be an upgrade
over a 10 series most of the time.
So what's your point, Nvidia?
Final word then.
It's a good product at a
bad price from a company
that is failing more and
more to hide its ugly nature.
You're gonna buy it, you
always do, and you know what?
You'll probably be happy with it,
but I don't have to be happy about that.
What I am happy to tell
you about is our sponsor!
- Jackery!
Jackery makes solar-ready
portable power stations
designed to improve outdoor
life by providing power outdoors
whenever and wherever you need it.
Before they used to use
maple syrup for that.
Their new solar generator 1000 Pro
is their fastest solar and
wall recharging generator yet,
boasting three times faster charging
than the normal SG 1000.
It consists of a Jackery Explorer 1000 Pro
portable power station
and 80 watt solar panels.
Plug it into the wall
and get a full charge
in under two hours and deliver
up to a hundred watts of power
thanks to the new 100
watt power delivery ports!
So check out the new Jackery
Solar Generator 1000 Pro
at the link below.
- If you guys enjoyed this video,
go check out our review
of the Radeon 7000 series
for a little more on what Nvidia
is up against this generation.
AMD seems to be catching
up, slowly but surely,
even if they too cost a fortune.